[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Merci, je t'avais bien
Prévenu aujourd'hui
je suis qui
tu as une petite
fille ce garson t'a
laisse aujourd'hui
que les yeux pour mieux le
pleurer à ce moment tu Ne voyz que
lui quand je t'pour la
foi
une petite
pu Je Ne peux Plus rien pour toi
aujourd'hui
j'ai troué la mour pour
ci Non Non une Petite
p tu m'as élevé énormément
amure aujourd'hui
tu m'as élevé TR
sécurisé tu verras Moi de
tesir tellement que chacun fait que le peigne
je vois que tu
Critique Oh petit
Chris
maintenant c'est bien trop tard
la
vie quand l'autre ne veut
pas Non Non un petit cri
oui Petite
fille Petite
fille Petite fille
[Musique]
ou
concernant